in the last video we learned a little
bit about the circle and the circle is
really just a special case of an ellipse
and it's a special case because then in
a circle you're always an equal distant
away an equal distance away from the
center of the circle while in an ellipse
you're the the distance from the center
of the circle is always changing and you
know you know what an ellipse looks like
it's I will actually do that in the
first video it looks something like that
what I mean that the radius or the
distance from the center is always
changing let me say this is centered at
the origin so that's the origin right
there you see here we're really if we're
on this point on the raid on the ellipse
we're really close to the origin this is
actually the closest we'll ever get just
as close as we'll get down here and when
we're out here we're really far away
from the origin and that's about as far
as we're going to get right there so a
circle is a special case of this because
in a circles case the farthest we get
from the origin is the same distance as
the closest we get or in other words
where we are always the exact same
distance away from the origin well with
that said let's actually go a little bit
into the math so that the general or the
standard form for an ellipse centered at
the origin is x squared over a squared
plus y squared over B squared is equal
to one where a and B are just any two
numbers they're going to I could have
written this as C squared + d squared I
mean they're just placeholders but just
give you an idea of what this means if
this was our ellipse in question right
now a is the is the length of the radius
in the X direction
remember we have a squared down here so
if you take the square root of whatever
is in the denominator
a is the X radius so this distance in
our in our little chart right here on
our little graph here that distance is a
or that this point right here since
we're centered at the origin will be the
point X is equal to a y is equal to 0
and of course this point right here this
will be a this distance is also a so
this would be the point minus a comma 0
and then the radius in the Y Direction
we
be this radius right here and this is B
so this point would be X is equal to 0 Y
is equal to B likewise this point right
here would be X is equal to 0 Y is equal
to minus B and the way I drew this we
have kind of a short and fat ellipse you
can also have kind of a tall and skinny
ellipse but in the short and fat ellipse
the direction that you're short in
that's called your minor axis and so B
you could always forget the exact
terminology but B you can kind of you
call it your semi or the length of your
semi minor axis why is it so let me
write that semi minor axis and where do
these that word come from well if this
whole thing is your minor axis or maybe
you can call it your minor diameter if
this whole thing is your minor diameter
it's called minor because it's the
shortest of the all of the diameters of
this ellipse and then the semi is half
of that right semi just for 1/2 so this
is the length B is the length of the
semi minor axis semi minor axis that's B
in this example just because as I drew
this ellipse it just happens to be that
B is smaller than a if B was larger than
a I would have at all I would have a
tall and skinny lifts let me actually
draw one it could have been like this
right I could have an ellipse that looks
something like that in which case all of
a sudden B would be the semi-major axis
because the B would be greater than a
that this would be taller than it is
wide but let me not confuse the graph
too much and in this case a is the
length of the I think you've guessed it
a is the length of the semi-major axis
or you could even call it the length of
the major radius I think that makes more
sense major radius major radius and you
can call this the minor radius I don't
like that color minor radius
minor radius so let's just do it an
example and I think when I did an
example with actual numbers it'll make
it all a little bit clearer so let's say
I were to show up at your door with the
following if I were to say x squared
over nine plus y squared over 25 is
equal to one so what is your radius in
the x-direction well your radius to the
X this is your radius in the X Direction
squared so your radius in the X
direction if we just map it we would say
that a is equal to three because this is
a squared and if we were to just map it
we say this is B squared then this tells
us that B is equal to five so if we
wanted to graph this and once again this
is centered at the origin
let me draw out the ellipse first so
first of all we have our our radius in
the Y Direction is larger than our
radius in the X direction so it's going
to lips is going to be taller and
skinnier it's going to look something
like that draw some axes so that could
be your x axis it could be your Y axis
so this distance this is this is your
rate your radius in the Y direction so
this distance right here is going to be
five and so will this distance and this
is your radius in the X direction so
this will be three and this will be
three that's it you have now plotted
this ellipse nothing to fancy about it
and actually just to kind of hit the
point home that the circle is a special
case of an ellipse we learned in the
last video that the equation of a circle
is x squared and a circle centered at
the radius a centered at the origin x
squared plus y squared is equal to R
squared so if we were to divide both
sides of this by R squared we would get
and this is just a little algebraic
manipulation we would get x squared over
R squared plus y squared over R squared
is equal to one now in this case your a
is R and so is your B
so your your semi minor axis is our and
so is your semi major axis Azhar or in
other words this distance is the same as
that distance and so it will neither be
short and fat nor tall and skinny it'll
be perfectly round and so that's why the
circle is a special case of an ellipse
so let me give you a slightly it look a
lot more complicated and this some
something you might see on an exam but I
just want to show you that this is just
a shifting let's say we want to do let's
say we wanted to shift this equation
this this ellipse let's say we wanted to
shift it it to the right by by 5 so we
wanted to shift that to the right by 5
so the instead of the origin being at X
is equal to 0 the origin will now be at
X is equal to 5 right so way to think
about that is what does this term have
to be so that at 5 we this this term
ends up being 0 well I'll actually draw
it for you cuz I think that might be
confusing so if we shift that over the
right by 5 the new equation of this
ellipse will be X minus 5 squared over 9
plus y squared over 25 is equal to 1 so
if I were to just draw this ellipse
right now it would look like this
it would look I want to make it look
fairly similar to the ellipse I had
before look it would look just like that
just shifted it over by 5 and the
intuition we learned a little bit in the
in the circle video where I said oh well
you know if you have X minus something
that means that the new origin is now at
positive 5 and you could memorize that
you can always say oh if I have a minus
here that the origin is at a you know is
is at the the negative of whatever this
number is so it would be a positive 5
and you know if you get a positive would
be the opposite of that but the way to
really think about it is is now if we go
to X is equal to 5 when X is equal to 5
this whole term this whole term X minus
5 will behave just like this X term will
here when X is equal to 5 when X is
equal to 5 this term is 0 just like when
X was 0 here so when X is equal to 5
this term is 0 and then Y squared over
25 is equal to 1 so you have Y has to be
equal to 5 just like over here when X is
equal to 0 Y squared over 25 have to be
equal 1 so Y is equal to either positive
or minus 5 so in either case positive
minus 5 but I really want to give you
that intuition and then let's say we
wanted to shift this equation down by 2
all right so if we wanted to shift it
down by 2 so our new ellipse look
something like this and this isn't
anything this isn't you know when a lot
of times you learn this in conic
sections but this is true of any
function when you shift things you shift
it this way if you shift it if you shift
this graph to the right by 5 you replace
all of the X's with X minus 5 and if you
were to shift it down by 2 you would
replace all the Y's remember we're
shifting down by 2 so you replace all
the Y's with y plus 2 so let me draw our
new ellipse first just to show you what
I'm doing so it's all good it's going to
be a little bit it's going to be shifted
down by 2 so our new ellipse it's going
to look something like it's going to
look something like that
so I'm shifting it down by 2 I'm
shifting the yellow ellipse down by 2 so
this equation if I shift it down well
well the X is still where it was before
X minus 5 squared over 9 plus y plus 2
squared over 25 is equal to 1 and once
again the reason I know this is because
now when Y is minus 2 this whole term is
0 right 0 when y equals -2 and when this
term is 0 it behaves the same thing as
when this term was 0 so when y is equal
to minus 2 you get the same behavior
you're the same point you're at the same
point in the curve right here actually
as you are when y equals 0 and this one
so here so it's not the same point you
can kind of view the same part of the
ellipse right you're at kind of the
maximum you're kind of the maximum with
point on the ellipse here and here when
y is equal to 2
and you were here at y equal to zero and
that's because when sorry when y equals
-2 right this is minus 2 and that's
because when you put y equal minus 2
here this whole term is 0 just like when
y was 0 here I don't to hit I don't want
to make it too confusing but just to
kind of wrap it all up sometimes you
might see something like you know graph
the following y minus 1 squared over 4
plus X plus 2 squared over 9 is equal to
1 and so the first thing you could say
is okay this is just like the standard
ellipse Y squared over 4 plus x squared
over 9 is equal to 1 it's just like this
but it's shifted over right this one's
origin is 0 0
well this one's origin would be what it
would be the point X is minus 2 and Y is
1 so if you were to graph this your
radius in your Y Direction is 2 right 2
squared is equal to 4 your radius in
your X Direction is 3 3 squared is equal
to 9 so let's see so your X radius is
actually larger than your Y radius so
it's going to be a little bit of a fat
ellipse it's going to be a little
actually let me draw the axes first so
that's my whoops let me draw it like
this
that's my vertical axis this is my x
axis and so my center is now at -2 1 so
1 2 that's minus 2 and I go up 1 so it's
up 1 that's the center of my lips and
now in the X Direction this is the X
term my X radius is 3 so the lips will
go 3 this is kind of the it'll go 3 in
that direction this is its widest point
will be 3 in that direction and then in
the Y direction it'll go 2 so it'll go
up 1 2 so that's there and then
one two and it's there so if I were to
draw that ellipse it would look
something like this
to my best shot it would look something
like that a little bit fatter than it is
tall and that's because your x radius is
larger than your Y radius right this
distance right here is 3 this distance
right here is 3 this distance right here
is 2 this distance right here is 2 and
if this is the point I'm you can figure
out what these points are I won't do all
of them right now just for the sake of
time but this right here is the point
minus 2 1 so if you go 3 more than that
so if you add 3 2 in the X Direction
this is the point 1 comma 1 if you would
take 3 way this would if you take 3 away
from the X Direction this would be minus
5 comma 1 and you can figure out the
other points that's might be a good
exercise for you anyway that's a little
bit on ellipses and in future videos
we'll do really hairy problems we have
to simplify it into this form so that we
know that it definitely is an ellipse